now are you gonna play cyberpunk 77 uh
only if i get a ps5
you can't play it on this i think you
can but i want to experience it
for you know the way it was supposed to
be intended it was attended on the ps5 i
think so yeah
so i can't download it on this probably
you probably can't just lower quality
oh okay because i want to play it
tomorrow movie probably i've been
playing i've been waiting 14 years for
it
fourteen yeah that was the last
cyberpunk no they've never made one
before i love how i play no but it's
it's an exaggeration they
not 14 [ __ ] years no but they've been
like you know i mean
saying that it was going to be released
last year and this and that it's been
like
yeah keanu reeves is in it uh i love him
i love like my new thing where it's like
i really do a good job pretending to
care
what do you mean that's true that's
something i'm working on
oh you don't care about cyberpunk i
can't no but what how have i been every
time you've been telling me about your
your victories but i understand but when
you're doing it though i understand what
you're doing
and i appreciate it the effort so when i
talk to her i go
she'll go like said like i'll be done
with warzone and she'll do something say
something ridiculous like how'd you do
babe right which i know she doesn't give
a [ __ ] that's friendly
it is friendly but i don't but it gives
me the opportunity
to at least say to somebody you know i
mean about the excitement of winning
because i know it matters to you and i
also genuinely want to engage your mood
if it's like we want and i know it's
like oh we're going to cuddle and watch
movies all night yeah and also what
drives her crazy the worst
is showing her the win i hate it
i love and i had to sit there for like
22 minutes just like
from beginning to end steve dylan and
him like
and it's yeah yeah like i don't
oh my god there was this one game oh yes
i'll tell you and it's like all i hear
is steve
you're a hero bob
it's a bit much but steve's calling you
a hero i know
no my brother will make me cry i believe
you my brother will go like
like bob i just want to say that i've
never been more proud of you
and i just think that like you know
you've improved and you're like a real
warrior
and it just and and in my mind i'm like
okay bob he's 19.
he's 20 years old yeah right when i i
know that he's you know what is he now
47 wow he's 47 years old
46 years but you still sell it in your
mind he's 19. no in my mind i go he's 19
he's 20. you know what i mean but
he uh he gets really emotional he gets
me all emotional about it you know
that's cool it's our way to [ __ ] bond
why not
you know why not yeah but so cyberpunk
uh
she she feigns you know look at me why
not why not
yeah here's an opportunity though she
said she does play a game called among
us so
and you know what i will play it and i
would like to engage and play with her
there was this other game that we're
playing like that um finding the
remember that once again the puzzles but
those are those aren't like actual
those are like puzzle games yeah i like
playing the puzzle juliana is is playing
valorent
is it ballarant oh oh wrong and fascist
valorent is that how you say it
can i just say this though is look at
a show like queen's gambit and we've
what two episodes that i love the show
i watch the whole thing she's seen the
whole thing have you seen it no or i
started it and i was a little bored at
the first episode so